etonnant non bon ça monsieur dame cher
public spectateur tout ça lâche 1 les
copains ça va bon là on est là au coin
du feu
ces rapports un entretien au coin du feu
pour avec monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing qui est président de dell qui
est présidente
c'est très bien de quoi il est président
c'est marqué sur la présidente de la
république française
normalement c'est jacques chancel qui
devait assurer l'entretien mais il est
un peu il un peu patraque c'est à dire
qu'il ay là il avalé un échiquier
il a passé une radio mais moi je vais
très bien faire la faire pour
l'entretien avec le président je pense
que le président devrait plus tarder
maintenant il est vrai même
[Musique]
bonsoir mon président bonsoir madame
bonsoir mademoiselle bonsoir monsieur je
suis venu pour répondre aux questions
que vous êtes en droit de nous poser
concernant l'actualité gouvernement
quatre pour vous chauffer les mimines si
vous remercie et j'aimerais d'ailleurs
élu d un certain nombre de malentendus
dont un qui consiste à prétendre que le
président connaît les questions à
l'avant bien c'est faux et ne connaît
que les réponses
ouais je vous écris ce monsieur le
président nous allons évidemment parler
des municipales annonce que non non ça
non non j'ai demandé quel de manier
vision n'en parle pas
alors vous êtes gentils vous vous
abstenez vous parler d'autre chose il y
à 2 millions jorge plus cruciale la
culture c'est quand même demain ses
marques et c'est pas demain dribbles il
ya plus crucial un peu voilà on peut on
peut peut-être parler du chômage s'étant
même préoccupant c'est bien je suis
heureux que vous me parliez du soma ah
ben on savait que nous connaissons vos
périodes de sorite de chômage en france
puisqu'il ya environ plus de chômeurs
cette année que l'année dernière mais
nettement moins que l'année prochaine ce
qui fait que grosso modo économiquement
parlant la franche arrive nettement
avant le brain lente
ouais bah c'est le principal face de mon
corps et de l'anglais il hante dix ans
vous êtes coins de l'inde il au bon ben
nott yeux le vestige giscard machin
appelé valérie chevalier tout ça je
pense qu'on pourrait maintenant aborder
le problème des municipales qui est
quand même assez n'ont eu qu'un jeune
âge j'ai demandé qu'on ne parle pas des
municipales à la télévision même pas
demain parce que ces deux maxis
écoutez il ya d'autres peut-être parler
du franc le france dont veut pas dire
que ce soit le favori pour si vous savez
le franc est fort quoi qu'on dit le
franc est stable francs et tenace on
peut parler du franchisé se vident à
blanc ouais bah c'est pas loin ce sont
ces planches d'un côté il y en a qui
connaissent le chemin
à bercy on peut pas parler de ça parce
que l'homme maintenant mon cher
lis tous deux ligues je vais t'appeler
chez big bang valérie valérie s'il est
un problème douloureux
actuellement c'est celui des municipales
qui comme nous mais on ne peut pas en
parler
pas du tout même nom alors si si un
problème pas de le re voilà on nous dit
de partout monsieur valéry qu
actuellement l'armée connaîtrait des
problèmes militaires notamment s'est
singulièrement il s'agirait il vaut
mieux qu'elles ne connaissent que des
problèmes d'ordre militaire
oui répondent à nantes oui et je me
dirais que j'ai tout fait pour rehausser
le prestige de l'armée puisque lorsqu'il
ya eu la grève des éboueurs
qui est-ce qui a ramassé les poubelles
si vous me ses présidents noctis et
l'armée c'est l'armée voyez la part des
finances que je lui témoin président
d'ailleurs vous savez que la france est
prête à résister à toute agression
à condition que ça ne tombe pas le jour
de la grève des éboueurs
c'est que nous avons de plus en plus de
femmes dans l'armée nous avons madame
desproges nous tellement on en
présentant l'étude de ma femme parce que
ça ne voudrait pas si elle était là
parce que mais oui les femmes
s'intéressent vous marier parce qu'on
trouvait ce sont des pans direct ce sont
des femmes est patente
je les passe en revue de temps j'entends
et elle me rassure je me dis avec elle
la france est inviolable ah bon alors on
glisse si on parlait des musiques
écoutées et moyens pour tout j'ai
demandé que l'on ne parle pas des
municipales à la télévision dans alors
on pourra peut-être aborder mon cher
valérie que vous allez voir comme c'est
pas de la tarte
le rapport à l'université l'université
connaît d'elle aussi des bas couture ce
qui concerne l'univers séité je dois
vous dire que la rentrée scolaire s'est
fort bien passé puisque j'ai demandé
qu'il y ait de plus en plus de crs de
façon à effectuer dans les meilleures
conditions possibles le ramassage
scolaire
oui alors voilà comment ça s'est passé
après un examen de passage aqaba les
élèves vont te tiens ramener chez eux la
plupart du temps dans jeunes sachent à
qui ce genre pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique française
weeks essentiel et fondamental
fondamental dans cette faune deux
oeuvres non ça n'a rien à voir mais
j'aurais aimé que vous me critiquer
cette femme vous mais il me donner votre
sentiment à propos d'une phrase que
monsieur mitterrand a dit l'autre jour
dans son langage admirable
enfin dans son langage banal dans dans
son jargon dégueulasse il a dit il
parlait il a dit enfin c'était pas très
intéressant je trouve quand même choisi
nous en a pris il est monsieur
mitterrand donc dit et en parlant de
marché monsieur marcher marcher et moi
nous sommes comme cul et chemise est ce
que vous pouvez délayé m'expliquer cette
phrase d'une grande beauté avant d'aller
au fond des choses
non on ne peut pas tout de suite parce
que moi je vous avez vous fait la vente
il faudrait savoir lequel des deux faits
la liquette oui en plus du tout mais de
toute façon vous vous en foutez vous
vous situez au dessus des partis
vous l'avez déjà dit vous n'avez
également alors c'est pas tellement mon
président pourra peut-être s'en aller
donc on ne parle pas d'eux ne peut pas
parler d'eux c'est bien simple on aligne
le droit de parler d'eux
ni des élections municipales qui ont
lieu demain de tous aux urnes césium
papa chef français madame mademoiselle
monsieur quand on n'a plus rien à dire
on se retire bonsoir faiblement non
[Musique]